Oh like Sameach hey you saved me a seat  it's for Elijah the Messiah you're no  Messiah huh what do you been talking to  my dad  that's my ninth Manischewitz I think  it's time to drain the old shofar you  guys doing sorry I'm late that rock on  my tomb was heavier than I thought  [Music]  are you ready to give you Easter sermon  yes but first let's pray and with our  eyes closed like really closed I was  turning wine into water yellow water no  one knows what I mean ooh tough crowd  are you guys Ephesians there just have  to do this story of the exodus  interesting well I was about to Exodus  to take this call  [Music]  [Applause]  sorry I had to step out for a hair where  were we  your Easter sermon of course you know  what I just gotta collect my thoughts  for one second I'll see you guys a  little bit Seder later back for dinner  but I cannot stay so I have to go bye  bye Jesus Christ what are you wearing  guess this might be my last supper with  you guys  [Music]  [Applause]